si
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es unser erstes garten
video in den instagram stories und auf
instagram tv habt ihr schon einiges
gesehen
jetzt möchten wir aber von ganz vorne
starten und euch sagen wie wir unseren
garten geplant haben
[Musik]
unser haus haben wir ja ganz alleine
geplant moore als bruder der weder der
ist bauzeichner und ich habe zu ihm
gesagt mir jetzt einfach nur ganz
wichtig küche im mittelpunkt
vorratskammer dran und dann die garage
und dann haben wir das haus drum herum
geplant also wirklich ganz viel alleine
überlegt und im garten haben wir das
genauso gemacht ich habe mir zuallererst
überlegt wenn ich im wohnzimmer und in
der küche stehe und nach draußen schauen
was möchte ich zuerst sehen natürlich
meine kinder deswegen haben wir eine
ganz große rasenfläche geplant und in
diesem video habe ich jetzt einfach fünf
schritte für euch zusammengefasst wie
auch er den perfekten garten planen
könnte ich war nun die gartenplanung am
anfang gar nicht so schlecht doch dann
haben wir durch zufall den christian
kennengelernt in der sap arena bei einem
konzert der christian hat eine
baumschule in mauer bei wiesloch und erb
sagt wisst ihr was ich schaue gerne mal
über eure gartenplanung drüber sagt mir
eure wünsche wird gestalten das zusammen
und er war auch derjenige der uns auf
diese fünf schritte gebracht hat also
erfahrt ihr in diesem video in fünf
einfachen schritten wie auch er den
perfekten garten für euch planen könnte
der erste wichtige schritt bei der
gartenplanung ist die bestandsaufnahme
das heißt ihr müsst euch fragen und auch
schauen was habe ich wohnt ihr bereits
in einem haus wo er den garten einfach
renovieren und neu gestalten möchte
habt ihr vielleicht gerade neu gebaut
dann schau dir einfach wie sie das
grundstück aus wo es die terrasse was
soll erhalten bleiben was kann
vielleicht weg und da könnt ihr euch
alles schön auf millimeterpapier zum
beispiel aufzeichnen und am besten auch
direkt im maßstab entweder 1 zu 50 oder
100 so könnt ihr später nämlich die
pflanzen dem möbel und alle anderen
elemente proportional und maßstabsgetreu
einplanen und bis dann auch ungefähr wie
groß die dinge jeweils sind und da ist
auch ganz wichtig die himmelsrichtungen
aufzuzeichnen also nie ohne seife
waschen denn bei der gartenplanung ist
wichtig wir wollen zum beispiel abends
in der sonne sitzen und nicht die
mittagssonne haben deswegen ist unsere
terrasse auf der ostseite da wo die
sonne aufgeht dann wandert die sonne und
wenn dann abendsonne ist haben wir hier
schön schatten schönen wind und können
abends immer im sommer auf der terrasse
sitzen ohne dass wir zu sehr schwitzen
da man dann immer eine schöne angenehme
temperatur für die gartenplanung sind
die himmelsrichtungen natürlich auch
wichtig denn es gibt pflanzen die wollen
in die komplette sonne es gibt pflanzen
die brauchen halbschatten und dann gibt
es auch pflanzen die können im schatten
wachsen also bei uns hier auf der
nordseite die brauchen nicht so viel
licht und ich habe es trotzdem immer
schön grün der zweite wichtige schritt
ist die wunschliste dann könnt ihr
gemeinsam mit der familie entscheiden
was möchten wir denn überhaupt im garten
und da ist es doch wirklich wichtig die
komplette familie mit einzubeziehen
die kinder brauchen platz zum spielen
ich brauche platz für meine nutzgarten
wo radbruch platz zum was auch immer zum
toben zum sich ausleben zum gärtnern und
da kann man wirklich eine schöne
wunschliste schreiben jeder kann auch
seine ideen mit einbringen und ihr könnt
dann eben auch feststellen was brauchen
wir denn alles also wir überlegen
einfach wofür brauche ich meinen garten
brauche ich ihn überwiegen zur erholung
möchte ich einen nutzgarten integrieren
habe ich platz für wasser wenn ja möchte
ich einen teich oder lieber einen pool
die große terrasse sein wo brauche ich
sichtschutz wo brauche ich sonnenschutz
und dann vielleicht noch praktischer
aspekte wie wo stehen die mülltonnen
brauche ich einen komposter oder auch wo
stehen die fahrräder und einige dinge
wie zum beispiel fahrradstellplätze
mülltonnen oder auch den komposter haben
wir uns bereits beim hausbau überlegt
das heißt wir haben mit moritz bruder
mit unserem architekten einfach schon
überlegt wo wollen wir die fahrräder
abstellen die stehen jetzt bei uns auf
der nordseite wo sind die mülltonnen die
sind natürlich dort wo man sie nicht
unbedingt sieht wo man aber trotzdem
praktisch drankommt wenn ihr neubau
können sie das bereits da schon
überlegen wenn ihr aber schon ein haus
habt und ihr wohl den garten komplett
umgestalten könnte da wirklich auch noch
mal die gartenplanung neu machen und
dann sagen ich möchte den platz völlig
verändern weil das wäre dann eigentlich
im prinzip die beste möglichkeit bei der
wunschliste ist natürlich auch ganz
wichtig neben den wünschen dass
finanzielle zu beachten das heißt ihr
habt eure wünsche ihr habt aber auch ein
finanzielles budget muss man natürlich
immer schauen vielleicht muss man auch
mal irgendwo sagen okay den einen baum
kann ich jetzt dieses jahr nicht leisten
aber dann lässt auf jeden fall platz bei
der gartenplanung und dann könnte sagen
im nächsten jahr im übernächsten jahr
kann ich dann meinen wunsch doch
irgendwann noch wahr machen und mir den
wunsch erfüllen und wenn ihr diese
unterschiedlichen wünsche dann
aufgeschrieben habt die finanziellen
aspekte berücksichtigt habt dann
entwickelt sich der garten plan
eigentlich fast schon von ganz alleine
ihr habt dann wie in einem haus
unterschiedliche zimmer wie zum beispiel
nutzgarten
rasenfläche für die kinder blumen fläche
für die bienen platz für liegestuhl für
die möbel und so entstehen die einzelnen
bereiche und dabei gibt es auch ganz
wichtige tipps der nutzgarten zb der
braucht natürlich fürs aroma- und für
den geschmack ganz viel sonne sieht aber
auch nicht ganz so hübsch aus das heißt
ihr könnt ihr zudem süden platzieren
aber vielleicht auch dort wo man nicht
unbedingt vom haus aus oder von der
terrasse aus direkt drauf schauen muss
also haben wir der nutzgarten einfach so
ein bisschen zur seite geschoben so dass
die sicht in den garten schön frei
bleibt gibt ja auch viele die wege in
den garten möchten also stein wege oder
auch was gepflastert ist ich bin da eher
so ein bisschen zurückhalten denn wir
haben auch die rasenfläche da laufen wir
gerne drauf und ich find wege die
zerteilen den garten immer so ein
bisschen das heißt wenn es nicht
unbedingt braucht last zweck oder macht
einfach sehr zurückhaltende wege jetzt
gehts weiter mit dem dritten schritt die
grobplanung da solltest du dir einfach
drei dinge überlegen da überlegst du dir
einfach welche art der linienführung die
am besten gefällt er geradlinig und oder
zum beispiel auch geschwungen dann
überlegst du natürlich auch welche
farben die am besten gefallen dass es
gerade bei der blüten auswahl ganz
wichtig und dann solltest du vielleicht
noch wissen welchen stil du haben
möchtest möchtest du einen naturgarten
der schön wild wächst oder möchtest du
vielleicht einen modernen und
reduzierten garten allen fernöstliche
asiatischen garten den romantischen
garten mit vielen übrigen blüten oder
zum beispiel auch einen mediterranen
garten
damit er möglichst unterschiedlich viele
ideen ausarbeiten kannst nimmst du am
besten transparentpapier legt es auf
deine planung drauf und da kannst du
dich dann ausprobieren da kannst du mal
schauen gefällt die retter mediterraner
garten gefällt dir geradlinig
geschwungen möchtest du ein paar wege
mit einarbeiten direkt grenzen setzen
und mit transparentpapier habt ihr
einfach die möglichkeit des
transparentpapier immer wieder
auszutauschen oder gegenstände zu
verschieben und dann seht ihr auch
direkt auf dem papier wie sie später der
garten aus und der entwurf der dir dann
am meisten gefällt das wird dann der
entwurf der in die detailplanung geht
wir hatten ja der plan meyer 1
politik macht und wir zudem christian
sprechender merken halt das ist ganz
anders machen wir die pflanzen bescheid
weiß und weiß wo ist nutzgarten wo ist
ihr garten damit ein riesenunterschied
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
kommen wir jetzt zum vierten schritt zur
detailplanung bei der detailplanung
werden dann die dinge die du vorher in
der grobplanung aufgesetzt hat in die
tat umgesetzt das heißt aus dem
sichtschutz wird dann eine hecke aus dem
sonnenschutz wird eine große platane und
aus den farben die die am besten
gefallen werden dann zum beispiel seine
lieblingsblumen bei der detailplanung
ist nicht nur der stil und die optik
wichtig da ist natürlich auch wichtig
dass der garten schön praktisch ist das
heißt da könnt ihr nochmal genau darauf
schauen habe ich genügend rasenfläche
für die kinder zu spielen ist die
terrasse groß genug habe ich genügend
platz für ein blumenbeet und solche
dinge und wenn ihr irgendwie seht da
passt etwas nicht geht einfach noch mal
einen schritt zurückgeht nochmal an die
grobplanung arbeitet alles noch mal
schön aus und dann geht es weiter wieder
zur detailplanung jetzt kommen wir zum
fünften schritt das ist die
pflanzenauswahl und viele machen den
fehler dass sie die pflanzen direkt
schon bevor sie den garten angelegt
haben schon aussuchen aber das ist
wirklich der letzte schritt denn jetzt
wisst ihr nach eurer grob und
detailplanung welche fläche habe ich
welche pflanzen brauche ich welche licht
und bodenverhältnisse hab ich und dann
könnt ihr nach draußen gehen und die
pflanzen richtig schön aussuchen und bei
der pflanzenauswahl legt ihr euch
wirklich ans herz geht in der baumschule
oder zu einem örtlichen gärtner der
wirklich die pflanzen auch selber zieht
denn er hat die pass sondern
klimatischen bedingungen wie ihr zuhause
auch die pflanzen kommen dann nicht
irgendwie von r fernost oder aus einem
anderen land war einfach andere
klimatische bedingungen sind und ihr
habt dann wirklich auch die garantie auf
die pflanzen bei euch im garten halten
das so schön werden dass sie blühen dass
die obstbäume obst tragen und so weiter
also das ist wirklich super wichtig ist
im ersten schritt vielleicht etwas
teurer als sonst aber ihr habt wirklich
auch eine garantie dass auch alles bei
euch im garten rex
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also dass immer jetzt ja bei euch im
elliot und der christian hat er gesagt
guck mal über die pläne trüber genau wie
habt ihr mir zugeschickt ich habe gesagt
da gucke ich gerne mal drüber und dann
gibt es ein bisschen meine meinung
garten ist ja heute der erweiterte
wohnraum und wirkliches leben findet
viel im freien statt auch mit freunden
zum spiel in der freizeit und wir wissen
wo ist es sonnig wo ist es weniger
sonnig ihr kennt den boden oder der
boden in waghäusel denn den kennen wir
auch der sand liegt genau das hat die
gartenplanung haben jetzt gemacht und
jetzt suchen wir uns die pflanzen jetzt
komm' mir spaß
es komme zu meinem element hier draußen
auch so schön
also das ist im prinzip unser lebendiger
sonnenschirm der sonnenschirm das
sogenannte dach platane die oben und
ganz dichtes dach ausbildet und gemüse
und idealer sonnenschirm beziehung
schattenspender für ihn hat das so
erzogen nennt sich dann auch noch gar
kein besonders schwer hier draußen und
es ist immer eine ganz andere luft die
aussöhnung schaden kommen wie bei einem
song laterne ist durch züchtung
entstanden ist kein baum der so in der
freien natur vorkommt jetzt wird es als
cooles christian aber weißt du was auf
ihrer wunschliste ganz oben stand
pflegeleicht und pflegeleicht ja was
manchmal im winter also die die palmers
einfach nicht 100 prozentig france fest
die gehört in den ersten jahren oben
immer eingepackt und und das ist einfach
aufwand und hat auch nichts mit dem
natur nach und so weiter zu tun als ich
weiß ist weiß ist will heinisch weiter
wird eine reiche und dann kommen wir mit
einer palme ja okay das komplett nur die
wenigsten schöner schattenspender und da
sind feigenbäume zeigen hätten wir gern
auf jeden fall können stand bei dir bei
der wunschliste ganz oben
die sie auch gerne verwehrt ist in
zahlreichen gerichten und das sind jetzt
kleinere exemplare fragen die aber auch
schon früchte so kleine exemplare oder
sie tragen auch schon vereinzelt früchte
die sind jetzt 45 jahre alte bekannte
bei der feige da würde ich nach einem
größeren jahresvergleich ernten kann ja
auch ein bisschen zu unserer kultur ja
in den feigen sind für mich so heimisch
weil immer wenn wir in der türkei sind
bei meiner tante in java das immer ins
dorf gefahren und dann haben wir da hat
diesen fragen bäume und das ist ja auch
high max in den ofen schieben sie für
euch
[Musik]
das machen wir so live richtig schwere
elemente der schutz der moral wie
kriegen wir voll oder die kriegt davon
so ich mache dir ruhig weiter ja so
genug paar sachen alles klar
ich meine jeder kennt ihn jeder will ihn
denn nur jeder kennt ihn jeder
du hast ihn ähnlich wie beim lament dass
du auch haben macht und ihr partner aus
unserem garten habe ich dann habe ich
libellen gefunden die zeigen ein paar
vögel
und dann haben wir vorne bei uns in der
küche den bereich zum naschen und da
hätte ich einfach ganz gerne alles was
man essen kann alles was uns schmeckt
erdbeeren brombeeren johannisbeeren was
heimische braunkohle wochen also keine
so so so ab sommer über im supermarkt
bekommen bringen was genial culina und
das ist eben das problem bei denen die
heute im supermarkt lehrern dass sie
nicht von alleine funktionieren und das
wollten wir bei unseren fruchtbringend
anders machen dass wir einfach sagen
können hänge der frucht bender den haben
wir alles mitgegeben haben damit es bei
euch oder auch bei anderen im garten
funktioniert und man holt sich hier den
frucht bringen
in drei altersstufen und es funktioniert
immer also hat immer eine ernte garantie
genau bei den beiden hohen altersstufen
können wir versprechen dass sie in
diesem jahr schon schon trägt also wir
haben die zweijährigen jungen wilden wir
haben die vierjährigen pfundskerle und
wir haben die sechs zellen gebracht
stücke mit welcher ich werde ganz klar
jetzt ist auch ein junger wilder
ich will auf jeden fall ganz viele
früchte haben um marmelade zu kochen
die kinder sollen wenn sie im garten
spielen einfach an die tische gehen an
die bäume gehen und sich was holen zum
naschen dass wir nicht richtig schön
wir pflanzen jetzt alles bei uns im
garten ein aber was macht man wenn man
es keinen garten hat kann man das auch
auf der terrasse oder auf dem balkon
sitzen also im prinzip so dass du die
ganze frucht bringen eben auch im kübel
halten kannst wackler haft in kühl
halten kannst du dass du damit eben auch
die möglichkeit hast auf balkon terrasse
dir dein eigenes core zu ziehen dazu
nicht aus und auch in kombination zum
beispiel du hast ein apfelbaum und und
dann hast du die app besitzen oder dass
die kräuter sitzen also das lässt ganz
ganz viele kombinationen können wir bei
mama auf der terrasse nämlich auch noch
pflanzen will hat hier oben weiß ich
auch aus dem raum bern kenne ich ja auch
so heimat ebenso hausen der türkei und
im haus meiner eltern ist ein trumpf
eigen und maulbeeren in allen farben
wirklich auch weiß war schwarz rot alles
daran gedacht dass schmidt essen
mein papa hat immer gesagt ist es
einfach mit
breinig den marken ja ja ich kenne das
auch aus der heimat aus marktkreisen
dann auch ganz viele man auch ne
[Musik]
bei den high die band gibt es ja weiße
innen und blaue innern ist es ein
unterschied also heidelbeeren blaubär
ist ja eine so die anderen so oder so
die bezeichnung heidelberg oder blau
wäre meinte immer das gleiche
das ist ein bisschen von region zu
region abhängig beim ssv werden hier bei
uns glaube ich eher die heidelbeeren
außen immer alle blau während die urform
video sie teilweise noch im wald findest
du jetzt auch ihnen blau
ja also die normale wilde form der blau
oder heidelbeeren es innen blau
so bekommt man so auch gefroren deswegen
nehme ich ganz gern bett horten immer
die gefrorenen heidelbeeren weil die
anderen auch so schön dunkle sind und
bei den kulturheidelbeeren das ist das
was wir am meisten auch als als strauch
verkaufen
da hat man während der züchtung die
blaue ihnen farbe weggezüchtet warum
haben weil die leute keinen blauen mund
im anschluss haben wurden also das hatte
ja das färbt ja richtig intensiv sein
also zunge zähne alles ranzen so naschen
ist wahrscheinlich besser aber dafür
traten und creme dann brauchst du keine
lebensmittelfarbe das den schönen lila
pink färbung hat sie natürlich erfahren
also manchmal hier von scale also nicht
fertig aber vier jahre alte guck mal was
er uns auch schon drauf hin zu vielen
stellen oder zwetschge da kann man sich
auch darüber streiten ob das gel
reingehört oder zwetschge aus dem
schwäbisch kommt zb bei den 80er oder
pflaume sage jetzt aber blaue sage wird
zu der runde und steht so lange zur
ovale ja genau die eine hat mehr
fröhlich als die andere
unser garten foundation zwei meter hoch
über noten gern noch ein bisschen mehr
sichtschutz das heißt wir können hier
diese spaliere nehmen der am unten so
ein ganz dünnen stammen und das stört
nicht im garten genau der wurde so
gezüchtet kinder oder sowieso dazu noch
mal gezwungen
ja und dann haben sie hat hier oben
diesen sichtschutz und ist echt schön
war da kannst du unten einfach das
einpflanzen und oben hat straften den
sichtschutz genau aber ich bin 180 2
meter unserem ja das passt ja christian
ich mir auch mal so ein baum das ist aus
wiesenbronn sei falsch dass ich meine
wenn der olivenbaum so aussehen würde
den boden sein oder noch irgendwas
anderes so bunt sei mäßig finde das
passt gut in unsere button darf nicht
weiß wir haben ja eher militärangaben
aber ich finde das glück die man einfach
cool auch im winter im sommer genauer zu
der frage passt es in euren garten wir
haben verschiedene zimmer und sowas ist
natürlich am teich immer eine super
sache
also insofern hätten wir einen platz um
sowas unterzukriegen also die idee kommt
ja aus denen im tempelgarten in asien
und es gibt zwei versionen warum man
angefangen hat gehört es so zu gestalten
dass eine ist der mensch wollte immer
schon mal wolken nachgestanden der murat
ist ab heute 1
da darüber will das ja ein junger wenn
sowohl im kristallinen prachtstück
wenige noch ein bisschen wachsen und ein
bisschen prachtstücke sie mit
bollerwagen und visionen später okay
jetzt haben wir jetzt haben alle
pflanzen auszug so weit vor dem ersten
step schon mal das heißt du kümmerst
dich dann einfach um die lieferung ja
und wir organisieren ein paar leute die
uns helfen beim einpflanzen um mama papa
die kids die nach familie freunde alles
zusammen bringt ein paar jungs mieten
wenn man richtig schöne pflanze ich das
cool und wir gucken jetzt noch ein
bisschen natürlich den shop ohne ullrich
noch ein passender deko und dann sehen
wir uns daheim bei uns im garten und
beim bepflanzen
im frühsommer
[Musik]
es ist also bis zum bestand bis dann
habe einen bollerwagen mit jeder
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie schön schatz guck mal das ist auch
der unterschied zwischen mann und frau
guck dir meinen schubkarren schön
dekorativ mokiert eine forscherin
ja aber bei mir könnte sogar den
schubkarren einfach vor den garten
stellen wollen wir noch sortieren
ja aber nur nicht fällig ich habe ein
alpaka gesehen
es ist doch flauschig mein gott
und das bindet beide der 30
[Applaus]
[Musik]
endlich wird der garten gemacht wir sind
schon seit halb acht hier draußen jesus
gerade kurz nach acht aber es hat sich
schon richtig viel getan
die pflanzen wurden jetzt alle schon
reingetragen der christian ist da die
baumschule und ich freue mich schon mega
auf heute denn heute wird endlich der
garten grün jetzt mal noch ein christian
da hinten ist ja gerade noch am auto
aber der erste baum steht schon guck mal
hier
hallo morgen hier
der allererste v ja so cool
jetzt brauchen wir nur noch viel sonne
die nächsten wochen viel sonne und der
murat muss es gießen
und hier ist gerade die kräuterwiese
alles voller kräuter wenn jetzt hier
stehen würde hier riecht's nach
französischen kräutern italienische
kräuter türkische kräuter alles bunt
gemischt sie fallen schafft all die
rezepte ein
aber jetzt müssen sie erstmal gepflanzt
werden und dann dürfen sie wachsen und
dann mache ich was draus bei euch
[Musik]
hier draußen vor einer küche da wir
jetzt der bank da kommen heidelbeeren
himbeeren erdbeeren dann machen wir so
ein schönes buch paradies einfach bengel
paradies ich meine jetzt eigentlich nur
noch auf der christian der organisiert
hier alles aber der hat alles gut im
griff
die gartenarbeiten zeigt ua wird immer
gesagt das beruhigt sehen sie in der
erde so spielen kann und vergebt mir
auch ich habe mich so lange auf diesen
tag gefreut
das ist in unseren augen die die beste
erde die ja verwenden knacken
was ist terra preta terra preta ist aus
der idee heraus entstanden wie die
südamerikanischen ureinwohner ihre
flächen buchbar gemacht haben und
nämlich durch brandrodung haben sie ja
sich praktisch für den ackerbau flächen
geschaffen haben dann gemerkt dass die
kohle unwahrscheinlich ist für den boden
und eine unwahrscheinlich viele
nährstoffe hat und dieser kohlenstoff
der drin ist gleichzeitig wie in
antibiotika für den boden wirkt okay
okay und das ist diese terra preta
[Musik]
ein nährstoffreicher boden und wir
müssen jetzt gucken das einfach die
pflanzen gut wachsen heute wieder alles
gesetzt und unser boden hier ist sein
erster farm wir hatten hier früher
spargel zwar alles spargelfeld und alles
nur sandig und da wächst ja eigentlich
außer spargel nicht so richtig gut daher
muss jetzt der boden schön gepflegt und
angereichert werden
und so kann man alles schön wachsen und
gedeihen wenn sie im garten zu trocken
ist und du machst mineralischen und
finger drauf zieht er unter umständen
sogar ich halte fest geht raus aus dem
boden raus aus der pflanze fehlt ok und
da fehlt ein manchmal einfach des
fingerspitzen
wie viel ist denn richtig dass das
problem bei mineralischen dünger und
auch aus gründen der nachhaltigkeit sind
wir rein bei der organe und da wie oft
zu stattlichen zweimal im jahr zwei
frühe und herbst oder frühjahr und
herbst ist das schöne ist die organisch
funktioniert erst dann und wenn es warm
genug ist und wenn ausreichend
feuchtigkeit alles richtig das tier pro
tag
na ja da ist wo anno mit tränen also das
richtig planen
[Musik]
also sind im prinzip zwei komponenten
[Gelächter]
den rasen damit gedüngt
bei jedem hund beliebt wenn es anderen
aber steckt genau wir nicht mehr so tief
sein
also sind im prinzip 22 komponenten dass
an ihm an ihn sind die nährstoffe
stickstoff phosphor kali das ist hier
drin das sind so die basics und dann
haben wir noch den boden aktivator das
ist einfach zum anregung von den mietern
damit das bodenleben funktioniert alles
organisch es gibt an wie viel du kannst
nichts und ich hab jetzt kommt euch
grundsätzlich noch was mitgebracht
sensor den wir gemeinsam mit ein paar
partnern entwickelt haben diesen sensor
würde ich gerne bei euch einbauen
dieser sensor misst bei euch
nährstoffgehalt feuchtigkeit
er weiß im prinzip was fehlt den boden
okay das kann ich mir in maur anzeigen
lassen okay auf so einem dashboard okay
das kannst du dir anzeigen lassen die
auf dem rechner oder auf dem harry ok
auf meinen geschwistern würde ich immer
bei mir dann sind es genau wie bei uns
macht ja das sensor eigentlich dann
richtig gut sind weil wir pflegen
unseren garten selber habe keinen
gärtner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich geh mal rüber und danach im juli ist
es noch mal nachdem königin der spiele
café steht immer an der kasse steht
jedermann in seinem leben sollte mal ein
kind auf die welt bringen und ein baum
pflanzen
das kind soll die frau verbringen und
man soll den baum pflanzen und hausbau
mir hat schon mal genäht war schon
damals gemacht jetzt mal ganz ehrlich ja
okay ich bin ich unserem etat und rasen
okay und ich werden jetzt diesen baum
hier einpflanzen und so schnell kann es
nicht sein
juni gesicht ist er hat eine kleine
wurzel gut im weinbau machen dann haben
wir weniger arbeiten das ist so ein kurz
ruhen zu lassen sich und zwar müssen
einpflanzen wir müssen noch machen
ungefähr dass er dinge rein passt und
dann müsste man ein bisserl hier ist
weil da hab ich die markierung blauen
dann gehen wir rein in die mitte und
machen das noch kommt
[Musik]
auf jeden fall machen jetzt an anzahl
rein so wir brauchen ein paar
[Musik]
kann es sein dass sie zu möglichen
preisen boden zu hauen ist mal wieder
das macht sich nicht ob du musst einfach
hoch
[Musik]
es ist ein kokon strikt durch mal zeigt
uns einmal und dann mache ich es auch
habt ihr gesehen und innerhalb von gut
sagen die firma jetzt gedauert habe ich
diesen baum gepflanzt und zwar jetzt
machen wir folgendes wir machen jetzt
mit aldi eine kiefer mate und rum warum
zum schutz dass er nicht da ein pingelig
recht und das hat mich vor dem grund
dass hier nicht neue knospen kommen und
wachsen habe ich recht ja da wo die
debatte ist mit nachher der baum nicht
austreiben
das schöne große krone hat und hier
unten nackt ist und nach ein bis zwei
jahren kann man die matschie auch weg
machen so perfekt man hat gesehen
innerhalb von ein paar minuten habe ich
ein baum gepflanzt
wahnsinn
[Musik]
abrakadabra schöne spalier ein
wunderschöner apfelbaum wächst hier 66
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich wie die heiße guck mal
die heißen da steht pflanzung egal franz
um die implantate kurz wir sind stiefel
dessen war sich dessen name hier stets
uns war das sind über sieben millionen
menschen in deutschland können nicht
richtig lesen und schreiben
das ist das nicht so den apfelbaum den
haben wir letztes jahr bekommen zufällig
aber dass du auf 25 und der wert bei uns
oben gestanden in der wohnung das ist so
ein jahr
jana kult jonagold jonagored ja mal
gerecht werde
[Musik]
genau grad vorne dann links
super super moral
[Musik]
ja war dass bienen und insekten paradies
alles blumen blütenstauden alles für die
bienen ja toll und die blühen auch alle
zu unterschiedlichen zeiten
das ist sehr schön
den ruf lanz gerade einen immergrünen
teppich hier diese pflanzen die kommen
hier rein
damit die aber sich gut ins erdreich
festsetzen und die wurzeln sich
ausbreiten zum starken wachsen muss man
die vorher so ein bisschen auseinander
reißen und damit die wurzeln unten nicht
so dicht verfilzen sondern in die breite
wachsen dann ein loch buddeln und gar
nicht so tief denn später kommt sie noch
hinten muss oben drüber und dann sieht
man die pflanze nicht mehr dann kurz
rein drücken fertig und das verwächst
dann relativ schnell und dann ist es
hier immer grün
[Musik]
das ist barbara barbara kommt jetzt auch
in meinem garten habe ich endlich meinen
eigenen rhabarber die barbara barbara
ersten johannes b
das wie die kinder bekommen zum garten
finde ich weil du machst du diesen der
ganze prozedur wird und am ende entstand
die früchte es war schön und der zug
legte und redet mit ihnen und macht
sauber
jetzt gibt's buchteln mit buch glitzer
schnee und im video kommt immer näher
über wie toll dass hier glitzert es
glitzert wirklich krass so schön sind
fertig du kriegst die erste woche mit
marillenmarmelade ab nächstes jahr mit
der einmaligen marmelade sehr gut
rotherbaum wer oder himbeeren
johannisbeeren glaube birne und thomas
parteien sehr gut
ja ich jetzt schon fleisch mariniert und
das gebe ich hier einfach ein
thermometer rein schön in die mitte
das kommt jetzt im backofen oder über
mein handy kann ich dann kontrollieren
ob die perfekte temperatur erreicht ist
mein backofen benachrichtigt mich dann
deswegen kann ich so lange dann draußen
beide arbeiten
also in den kalten ofen perfekten
thermometer eingesteckt das passt und
ich würde jetzt entweder kammer jetzt es
ist machen aber ich mache jetzt einfach
ich gucke jetzt mal was besser ist
vorschlägt
[Musik]
man kann es nämlich danach noch
ordentlich auf dem grill schmeißen handy
nehme ich mit in der app sehe ich alles
wie weit der braten jetzt ist jetzt habe
ich gerade 14 grad kerntemperatur und
jetzt kann ich mich in die olivenbäume
kümmern
[Musik]
jetzt wird die olive noch gedreht weil
einfach die andere seite schöner ist und
wenn wir hier auf der terrasse sitzen
oder eben im esszimmer
dann haben die schönere die ansicht
seite und vor allem schaltet ihr da eine
art so ein bisschen zu sehr auf die
terrasse
das drehen wir um damit war auf der
terrasse kein platz verlieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im eifer des gefechts kann man mal ein
paar sachen vergesse ich habe den kübel
vergessen und zwar die sich eine
redensart kübel zu sagen wir bei uns
waghäusel und das komisch in waghäusel
es ist zwar jetzt samstag aber ich kann
den rudolfplatz anrufer und gucken ob
wir noch da ist wohl mit einem peter
zahner hol mir jetzt einfach den kindle
ab und ich hoffe dass wir die tür
aufmacht weil es die krise groß aber der
peta hat wird seinen hänger dabei
dann kriegen wir das hin zu
musikalischen der kopf kommt schnell das
ist genial wie sie hier waghäusel
da sind die leute auch samstags beim
schaffen hier schon rudolf geil das
christlich dankeschön so auch das ist
der gipfel ging ja und zwar dieser kübel
ihr sesam name das kommt aus dem namen
kübel aber bei uns umgangssprachlich
heißt dass kimmel richtig genau so
verhält sich unter den gibt es auch in
anderer farbe sauerstoff sehen können
gerade mit nehmer und haschen stapler
und er ist in hermannstadt
wahnsinn paketsparte richtig soll jetzt
noch weiter gespart und jetzt primär den
himmel komm raus oder regionen
er ist so cool mit solar coole leute auf
dem bau hat ist genial sste das ist mal
aufgemacht hat spielen dank ich weiß
echt ja schon abholer ich habe es nicht
die bäume zu sagen dankeschön auf
samstag ist das stück besteht nicht also
vielen dank für uns immer gas
[Musik]
für heute hat schafft ja ich denke wir
haben ja auch viel geschafft wir haben
sehr viel geschafft und alle sind
geschafft wir sehen uns dann wieder ein
paar wochen zu coachen perfekt dank
vielen tagen sehr gern
es gibt ja noch ein buch de placement
die buchteln die bucht christian da
jetzt noch mit den geschehnissen
jetzt ist der garten fertig angelegt
mittlerweile sind wir auch schon
wirklich fast fertig also der rollrasen
liegt schon der teich ist wert ist wenn
ihr möchtet man sich auch gerne videos
darüber wie wir den garten pflegen also
immer mal wieder früher herz und ihr das
wirklich schon gespannt sein auf das
nächste garten video ich bin jedenfalls
sehr
[Musik]
unser garten ist fast fertig die video
seht ihr alle auf einem kanal und
einfach richtig schön geworden und wir
wollen uns bei unseren freunden und der
familie bedanken die hier alle fleißig
mitgeholfen haben aber wir würden auch
gerne mit euch feiern
das heißt ihr veranstalter eine
gartenparty und weil hier nicht alle
personen und reinpassen verlagern wir
das ganze nach mauer und gehen da zum
christian in die baumschule zum
lebensraum müller in maur das ist bei
wiesloch da könnt ihr gerne alle kommen
die veranstaltung findet statt am 13
und die uhrzeit steht hier unten ihr
könnt gerne alle vorbeischauen der murat
ist mit arbeit dann seht ihr ihn live
wir dort die pflanzen gießt ihr könnt
uns fragen stellen ihr könnt vielleicht
auch fragen stellen rund um den garten
nicht vielleicht ihr könnt auf jeden
fall fragen stellen rund um den garten
wie sieht's aus mit gardiner
bewässerungssystemen was es mit dem
rasenmäher apotheke könnte die frieda
mal im einsatz sehen
ihr könnt aber auch unsere anderen
partner kennenlernen wie kitsch und
kenwood gassi und es sind auch mit dabei
und wir haben wirklich ganz viel viele
tolle sachen ich werde dort kochen und
backen oder grillen wir werden viele
leckere dinge zu bereiten eure kinder
können ihr mitnehmen denn für kinder
wird auch megaspaß kinderschminken wird
vor ort sein vielleicht auch noch eine
hüpfburg vielleicht habt ihr auch noch
weitere ideen die ihr gerne unser das
video schreiben können und dann freue
ich mich einfach auf euren besuch ich
freue mich euch kennenzulernen
lasst es krachen am 13 17 mauer woran es
mit dabei und mein ganzes team und wir
freuen uns schon auf euch bis bald